this is a production of Cornell
University and thank you everybody for
coming today it's really nice to be back
in the Horticulture Department I'm just
down the road now at DTI
but nonetheless this section sorry I
started in 2009 when departments still
existed instead so thank you doc it's
great to be back and to see familiar
faces and to have the opportunity to
share my PhD work with you today
so I like to start these talks on the
sorry on the rhizosphere microbiome I
like to start with the technical glitch
and then move on to thinking about why
we think about the rhizosphere and the
plant microbiome in general and for me
much of this is focused around the story
of nitrogen and agricultural systems as
you know it's a plant limiting nutrient
and most of our terrestrial systems
certainly in agricultural systems and
the application of nitrogen to our
agricultural lands has enabled a really
steep increase in the yields of those
lands
so as US average yields have gone up
over the last century so has nitrogen
application gone up for much of it and
it's going to enable continued gains in
productivity as well but there is a cost
so some of this and when nitrogen is
applied in excess or when it leaves
those agricultural lands it can leave as
a greenhouse gas nitrous oxide it can
also enter the waterways lead to
eutrophication so this is just a picture
of the hypoxic zone in the Gulf of
Mexico a result of nutrient loading in
the Mississippi River Basin and so the
challenge of crafting sustainable
systems in the future is how do we
maintain that plant productivity without
loading these environmental
externalities the rhizosphere is a
really exciting object to study in this
regard because it's a hot spot of
nutrient and nitrogen cycling in soil
and this nutrient cycling is really
driven by the fact that the plants
release about 3 to 30% of their fixed
photosynthate into the rhizosphere e
there is plant root exudates
or riser deposits and this carbon flow
enables a microbiome that is really
distinct from bulk soil it's both more
abundant more active and different in
composition and not only is the
composition different but we also see
that some of the process rates are
different as well and so we often see
increased rates of decomposition in the
rhizosphere and associated nitrogen
mineralization some of the estimates are
as high as ten times the amount of gross
nitrogen mineralization occurring in the
zone around plant roots is in bulk soil
and so this is a substantial nutrient
flow that might be available for the
plant to take advantage of and that
plants and their micro biomes may be
able to to tap into and when I find also
exciting is not only is this compartment
different from bulk soil but we see
variation between plants plant species
and even plant genotypes and their
impact on this environment the
composition of the microbial community
there and some of the process rates that
were interested in so in a horticulture
Department this is an interesting point
of intervention that we can have and
these met managed landscapes if we can
choose plants that harvest a beneficial
microbiome then we may be able to manage
some of these processes and supportive
plant productivity well while we know
that there's some plant variation in
this environment in the microbial
community that resides there we don't
have a good handle on or a good
predictive framework for understanding
which plants are going to have which
effects on on the rhizosphere and so one
of my main research questions is trying
to get a handle on at least in the types
of plants that we put into agricultural
fields what might be some sources of
variation in their rhizosphere effects
and again you know we're interested in
plant resource acquisition and so are
these impacts on the res is fear
bacterial community composition its
metabolism are they linked with
differences in plant growth and nitrogen
uptake in the fields and then finally
I'll end on a story looking back and
asking the question of has modern
breeding altered these relationships has
modern breeding influenced
Rises for your composition or function
as we've bred plants for our
agricultural landscapes have we changed
these interactions in any way the way we
address these questions and this will
hold true for all of the experiments
that I share today is a basic common
garden type experiment so we take a
range of plant diversity we plant it in
the same environment under the same
conditions and then we can see how the
plant genetics changed the phenotype
that we're interested in in the first
experiment that I'll share with you we
focused on maize and a handful of c4
grasses but also some broader diversity
including some dicots and legumes as
well and what this allows us to do is to
test things like our is plant
phylogenetic distance related to the
microbial community differences in the
microbial community between these plants
our plants that are farther apart on
this phylogenetic tree also share
differing more in their microbial
community and there's some indication
that this holds both in the rhizosphere
of the PO AC and the mammalian gut
microbiome that evolutionary history of
the organisms play a role in their
microbiome in shaping their microbiome
but it hasn't really been tested in the
field for for plants additionally these
plants are also distinct in other ways
and so there's a handful of crop plants
with large growth growth potential
sorghum maize sunflower some
agricultural weeds that are highlighted
in orange which have a different life
history strategy perhaps and then even a
legume and so another hypothesis
hypothesis would be that plants that are
functionally similar that share similar
growth characteristics may have similar
effects on the microbiome and plants
that are further apart they have more
disparate micro biomes so as I said we
plant these out in the field we use
replicated monocultures shown in the
upper right hand corner here we maintain
weed free bare soil control plots so we
can compare the rhizosphere samples that
we're collecting
soyal that's not under the influence of
plant roots and then we split these
plots with a nitrogen application of
zero or ninety five kilograms of
nitrogen correct there too to assay the
plant characteristics and the
rhizosphere traits under conditions of
severe and limitation or greater and
availability then we sampled all of
these plants at flowering time which is
an important distinction that you'll
hear more of as this talk goes on and we
did that because there's increasing
evidence that as plants go through their
phenology there Rises for your impacts
are changing and so rather than sampling
all these plants at the same time we
decided to set the phenological stage of
flowering and sample them all at that
point we harvest the above-ground
portions of the plant to measure biomass
nitrogen uptake if that we can calculate
nitrogen use efficiency which for us is
a very broad definition of just the
amount of carbon that the plant can fix
for the amount of nitrogen then it takes
off from the soil we dig the plants up
and we collect soil from around the
roots as well as intact roots and
adhering rhizosphere soils for profiling
the bacterial community and we're using
a 16s rRNA approach for that and then
collect the soil as well for lab based
assay of microbial community activity an
extracellular enzyme based assay so you
can get a idea of microbial metabolism
in soil and so some of the data the
first thing to note and I mentioned that
flowering time is going to be an
important thread through this section of
the talk is that when we're looking at
the plant traits that we measure not
surprisingly how long these plants grew
is the major source of variation so we
were looking for functional variation in
the plants and how long they're in the
ground for how long they take to flower
is the major dimension of diversity and
so flowering time whether it's biomass
or here I'm showing an uptake flowering
time describes most of the variability
in that
these extracellular enzymes for those of
you who aren't aware or just a reminder
these are extra cellular enzymes that
are produced by microbes released into
the soil break down organic
macromolecules cellulose lignocellulose
protein chitin releasing monomers that
are available for plant plant uptake in
the process liberating nitrogen and
phosphorus for the microbes as well
and if those microbes die or turn over
that those nutrients may be available
for the plant all right so a light show
to in so measuring these enzymes with us
through this assay we can get a picture
of microbial allocation in soil to these
different sort of pools of carbon that
are available or carbon and nitrogen in
the case of the lower two that are
available to them and we can measure the
same thing in the rhizosphere and we can
see this rhizosphere effect that I was
alluding to earlier an increase in the
activity of these EXO enzymes in the
rhizosphere soil for the 16s rRNA
profiling where essentially we're
collecting these roots from the field
we're taking intact roots and
rhizosphere soil extracting the DNA
amplifying a portion of the 16s rRNA the
v4 variable region and then sequencing
that on the aluminum iseek instrument we
run that through a bioinformatics
pipeline where we're demultiplexing
do a quality control and then we cluster
those at 96 7% similarity among the
sequences to form what we call
operational taxonomic units which are
just what we think of as taxa in this
data and that gives us two two forms of
data we have essentially species lists
that are occurring in each sample and
the relative abundance and then we can
take those and calculate dissimilarity
matrices which is comparing each sample
to each other how close is the
composition in one sample
to another and I'll share both types of
data with you today so this is taking
that distance matrices or donating it
showing it in a two-dimensional space
and essentially each dot represents a
microbial community a sample of a
memorial community those dots which are
closer together are more similar in the
composition of that community those
which are further apart are more
distinct so right off the bat there's a
very strong rhizosphere effect and
bacterial community composition these
triangles are all bare soil plots and
then these dots and you can see a very
clear separation and a wise separation
between the rhizosphere samples and the
bare soil samples explaining about 25%
of the variation in the data set now the
same same ordination color the same way
but the the color coding is actually the
day we're sampling and so what I'm
highlighting here is that what day we go
out and we collect these samples
influences about 33% of the variation in
the data set and that variation is
driven largely by the rhizosphere
samples so flowering time is image and
it's very important as far as the plant
characteristics that we're measuring we
also find it's very important in the
actual composition of the community in
the rhizosphere that said we can control
for it and then we can see what amount
of variation we can partition to the
plant genotype or skews effect and we
see about another 20% of that variation
so plant genotype and species is having
a substantial influence on the microbial
community and the colored dots in this
one are just indicating different
different species or genotypes not
supposed to be able to make sense of
that range of colored dots right now but
if you look you can see that these light
green ones separating here there's some
light blue ones so there you can pick it
up visually as well now in contrast
something like fertilization in the
rhizosphere really isn't that having
that great of an influence on the
microbial community that we measure it's
mystically significant because we have a
very large and when we're running this
test but it's only about one percent of
the variation that we're observing can
we attribute to the nitrogen
fertilization so that's great but that's
kind of where I started the the talk is
that we know that there's this variation
between species and genotypes but we
want to know what leads to that so
another way of looking at that and here
on the y-axis is you can think of as the
difference in microbial community
composition we're using a weighted unit
rack measured for that so that takes
into account both the composition of the
bacterial community but also the
phylogenetic relationships within that
community and then on the y-axis is the
days between harvest for each sample and
so what we see is a positive
relationship between time of sampling
and the microbial community composition
those samples that are collected further
apart are more likely to be distinct
those samples which are closed sampled
on similar dates more likely to be
shared and this is the the largest
source of variation in our in our data
set again we can control for that and we
can look at the same thing looking at
plant evolutionary distance and so we
used chloroplast our VCO and that
cadence to reconstruct a phylogeny of
these plants and we see a positive
significant relationship with the
weighted unifor act distant measurement
essentially saying that plants that are
more distantly related are more likely
to have a microbial community in the
rhizosphere that's more distinct and I
think it's much easier to visualize when
we sort of bin it into groups so if we
take it from the same genotype versus
within a species within a family or
between families we've heard of seed
more likely to get samples that are
distinct in composition so we wanted to
dive in and look at some of the
functional differences between plants
and what were the the effects on the
microbial community that these variables
were having and so this is another
ordination but some of you may be
familiar with redundancy analyses and
essentially what I'm doing is I'm
constraining the ordination to only show
that variation in the microbial
community that is explained by these
four explanatory variables and so we're
showing you a subset of the variation
and the relationships among this species
and how they relate and we we chose
these four variables because you know
days to flowering was the most
significant source of variation in the
data set but also plant nitrogen use
efficiency seed size and nitrogen uptake
nitrogen uptake was what you're mainly
interested in and the two other
variables were also significant
predictors though I didn't didn't show
you that data when we put these together
in an ordination what we find is that
all of these load very strongly on on
one axis and they essentially separate
out the plants on one side we have some
some meteor plants our barnyard grass
foxtail velvetleaf as well as some lower
carbon nitrogen use efficiency plants
crop plants so there's teff and finger
millet and here as well and then on the
other side some longer-lived
higher nitrogen use efficiency crop
plants such as maize sunflower and
sorghum and so there's this life history
difference that are separating plants
out that's related to both their plant
traits and associated with differences
in the microbial community as well we
can
take the tax in abundance and then
correlate it with this axis this first
axis of the ordination and so every dot
on this graph is is one of the taxa in
the data set those that are grey aren't
significantly correlated with that axis
those in red are and they're spread to
the left or right is essentially the
change in abundance as you go as you
move to the right or left of this axis
so these red dots are positively
correlated with the side of the axis
these red dots are with that side of the
axis and what jumps out is that there's
very strong phylogenetic selection on
the microbial community there's quite a
few Actinobacteria so this one phylum
that's strongly selected by these
long-lived high nitrogen use efficiency
plants and so we have a a plant life
history difference and some sort of
files genetic selection on the
rhizosphere microbiome and for those of
you are familiar the actinobacteria are
filamentous bacteria and so there may be
a morphological selection as well
we can further overlay some of the
enzyme data that we had and see how that
really how that matches some of these
relationships and so the three things
that I've highlighted are one leucine
immuno peptidase that's a protein
degrading enzyme in Ag is a as a chitin
a so these are both carbon and nitrogen
accessing enzyme and these are
negatively correlated with the axis
which is telling you that these are more
active potentially more active in these
longer lived higher nitrogen use
efficiency plants and this makes sense
these are plants that have to be in the
ground for a longer period of time
during the growing season they're
putting more resources into green for
the following season versus some weedy
or shorter lived species that maybe
don't have the same resource demands on
the soil or effects on soil over time
and also correlated with that axis is
inorganic in content so you can start to
see the congruence between some of the
the chemical variables the microbiome
and some of the plant traits as well all
right so to wrap up this initial part we
we see that host phylogeny does
influence rhizosphere bacterial
community composition a small but
significant effect and then that we see
this relationship in plant life history
strategy with the bacterial community as
well but I hope that you're wondering
you know how much of this is actually
influenced by the plants that we've
selected and their variation versus just
this decision to sample at flowering
time because we sort we certainly were
and then are these trends actually
linked with patterns of growth and
nitrogen uptake that are can be
separated from these differences in
flowering time so we ran another
experiment and this time we we focused
in on a subset of the variation that we
asked it in the first experiment we use
two maize hybrids and then sort of four
species that attempted to encompass the
functional variation that we observed in
the first so we used buckwheat forage
millet
Soudan grass and sunflower as well and
we planted these in a 20-year organic
field up in pinion in the summer of 2015
and here we sampled instead of sampling
at flower time we sampled it set dates
based on the phenology of maize so at
the vegetative stage which I'll show us
v6 its flowering stage r1 and grain
filling but we can now track what are
the species effects versus what are the
temporal effects in this data set we
added a fertility treatment again so
that we could see how these plants are
responding to resource availability it's
an organic field so we can't add
synthetic nitrogen to create this but
instead we mowed swaths of clover from
the season before and then transferred
that off of the the low end plots to the
high end plots transferring about 55
kilograms of nitrogen per hectare to set
up a fertility gradient and we measure
many of the same things and so here is
some of the basic growth data and I just
want to draw your attention to the fact
that these plants do vary in their
growth over the course of the season and
the one thing that I want to highlight
is that this is relative growth rate two
of these plants the Soudan grass and the
millet are really maintaining higher
rates of growth longer into the growing
season than than the others and so the
maize the sunflower and the buckwheat
are all decreasing their relative growth
rate at a faster pace measure nitrogen
uptake so we can see how nitrogen uptake
dynamics changes over the course of the
season and here I just want to note that
it's at the flowering time sampling
where nitrogen uptake is that it's
highest it peaks for almost all the
species at that point it's also when it
appears that nitrogen is most limiting
from the soil and so the bottom panel
graphs are broken out by each species
but they're also shown in the solid
lines show nitrogen rate of nitrogen
uptake in the plots where clover was
removed and the dotted lines show
nitrogen uptake and the plots where
clover was added
and it's only at this harvest at
flowering time where we start to see a
significant difference in the rate of
nitrogen uptake between the fertility
treatments which is telling us that at
this point nitrogen supply from soil is
limiting and the fertility treatment is
making a difference whereas it's not
limiting either before or really after
for that matter here's some enzyme data
again and I'm showing you just the
cellulose degrading enzyme and the
protease because I think they're the
most interesting story but these black
dots represent the bare soil while the
colored dots again represents the plant
rhizosphere semblance is though the
first thing to note on the top panel is
that the yellow and the blue dots that
represent the maize species or maize
genotypes they have this strong
rhizosphere effect on a cellulose
degrading enzyme early in the season
that's maintained through flowering and
that effect really is not observed for
any of the other species that we that we
assayed and so there seems to be some
species influence on microbial
metabolism in the soil that we can see
in our enzyme data the second thing I
want to highlight is with the protease
we don't observe a rhizosphere effect
early in the season but here at
flowering where nitrogen demand is
highest across the plant species there's
a positive rhizosphere effect on
potential enzyme activity and just a
reminder
course this is when we see nitrogen
being limiting nitrogen soil supply
being limiting and nitrogen demand at
its peak from the plant
so there's a synchrony between plant
nitrogen demand nitrogen supply from the
soil and the metabolism microbial
metabolism in the rhizosphere we can
dive deeper into this time point and
here I'm just regressing the rhizosphere
effect on this enzyme activity versus
the rate of nitrogen uptake for those
plots or species and we see a positive a
significant positive relationship in
these so we see synchrony importantly
but also the variation between species
in their effect is linearly correlated
with their nitrogen demand and this is
really exciting because if we think that
you know these enzymes the res fear
effect on these enzymes is a mechanism
of plant nitrogen supply and that this
represents nitrogen mineralization in
the rhizosphere which granted is a big
leap this data would be consistent with
nitrogen supply that is a result of the
rhizosphere effect and that's nitrogen
that's feeding a planet and that's not
available for loss from the system or an
eventual runoff so looking at the
microbial community data this is an
ordination that's been faceted into
three panels and so each of these panels
share the same ordination space but
instead only the points that are shown
are from the first second and third
sampling and so here we can see the
difference both over time and between
the species in our in our data set so
the first thing to note is that sampling
date does have a large effect in fact
the rhizosphere effect seems to be
getting stronger over the course of the
season and more distinct from bulk soil
and that's explaining about 11% of the
variation in our data set but also plant
genotype or species is having a very
strong effect to explaining more of the
variation even 18% but I think most
interestingly the there's this
interaction between genotype
and sampling date so about 10% of the
variations explained by this interaction
and essentially what we see in the
ordination is that plants are having
divergent effects on the microbial
community over the course of the season
essentially shaping the succession of
the rhizosphere microbiome in different
ways and so at our first sampling the
difference between species is really you
can't really pick it up visually but as
you move into flowering time you start
to see sort of these green points on the
sunflower that clouds separating up to
the upper right-hand quadrant Sudan
grass these red points beginning to
separate down and by the third sampling
millet Sudan grass sunflower and maize
all really in their own portions of the
ordination so not only a species having
an influence on the microbiome but it's
affecting the succession of that
community as well all right I promise
this will be the last of these that I
show you but again this is a constrained
ordination so we're looking at the
variation in the data set that in this
case is correlated or explained by these
other growth characteristics and I use a
slightly different set of growth
characteristics because we have better
measurements in this in this data set so
we have relative growth rate total
biomass accumulation and the rate of
nitrogen uptake and that nitrogen use
efficiency or the plant carbon to
nitrogen ratio metric and what we what
we see is that these plants really
separate predominantly on an axis that's
best explained by differences in
relative growth rate and so these
species millet Sudan grass occupying one
side of the axis and sunflower and maize
occupying another side of the axis and
when we look at the correlations with
the microbial community associated with
these axis we start to see a very
similar pattern some slight differences
with what we saw before but a similar
pattern where again the Actinobacteria
are associated with this group of
species lower growth rate higher biomass
accumulation over the course of the
season and a bra
their swath of diversity associated with
the plants with a higher relative growth
rate now there are a handful of other
things that are popping up not just the
actinobacteria in this game and one of
them is a group of chlorophyll XE and so
I mentioned before that you know the
actinobacteria are notable for this
filamentous lifestyle and the
chlorophyll XE the best hit to the group
that was changing was this family that
Contino back to your AC which is also a
filament dis bacteria and then of course
there's a burr cold area which is a
broad general BART broad genus many
plant growth promoting bacteria in this
genus including some nitrogen fixers so
it's not surprising to see it in the
rhizosphere but i think the fact that
this we're seeing this selection on the
filamentous lifestyle and this subset of
the octina bacteria now in two different
experiments in two different soils two
different years but associated with
similar sort of life history traits i
think is is notable and probably worth
following up so what have we learned so
far some of the enzyme data pointed out
that the rhizosphere function is is very
well coupled with plant nitrogen demand
in the data that plant species are
shaping the rises for your community
composition and the successional trends
in the data and then again these were
lower relative growth rate plants
favoring a subset of the microbial
community dominated by the
Actinobacteria and other filamentous
bacteria and so what do I think is going
on here there's been some work that has
looked at differences among plants and
relative growth rate and particularly
how they maintain that relative growth
rate under nutrient stress and Rises
fear effects as well and what they find
is a positive relationship between plant
relative growth rate and rises for your
carbon flow and in those plants that are
growing faster maintaining higher rgr
higher carbon flow then there's
increased microbial growth and turnover
in the rhizosphere of those plants
and so we can imagine that our plants
might be on the same axis and that those
those plants that are slowing their
relative growth rate later in the season
are is mirrored by a decrease in carbon
flow in the rhizosphere and thus a
narrowing of the ecological niche that
is somehow favoring the subset of the
community verses plants so this is a
picture of teff a lower nitrogen use
efficiency grass but that may be
maintaining higher rates of carbon flow
and then thus a greater diversity of
organisms in the rhizosphere okay so the
last thing I want to share with you
today is is really it's a means of
looking backwards in preparation to look
forward that is if it rises for your
selections associations can be selected
and bred for then it may be possible
that indirectly we've been selecting for
certain associations over time and so
we're back to this picture of changing
nitrogen use and increasing yields and
so the nitrogen management portion of
this is one component but also we've
been breeding over the course of this
60-year history in this graph and
breeding for improved yields in these
environments and so how is breeding
interacted with changing management
regimes and what are the implications on
that for the rhizosphere effects and we
can think of a sort of a simple
hypothesis would be if we've replaced
the soil nutrient flows with additional
externally applied nitrogen fertilizer
and we've been breeding for plants that
do well in that system we may have bred
for plants that as the throughout the
breeding history that are better at
taking up nitrogen from from fertilizer
but there may be a cost or there may be
relaxed selection on traits that are
supporting the plant gaining soil
nitrogen nitrogen from soil pools so
there may be a trade-off over that
period of time if we think about it and
turn
of microbial community similarity if
there's a relaxed selection on
rhizosphere traits over time then plants
that are really bred and released at in
similar time periods would be more
likely to have similar microbial
community composition whereas maybe
plants that were released early and
early in the history versus late in the
history may be more distinct effects on
the rhizosphere microbial community and
so to test this pioneer hi-bred
international now to pond pioneer
maintains a collection of their
best-selling hybrids from 1936 through
present-day and they provided us with
seed of 12 of the best-selling hybrid
sort of spanning this range and we
planted those out and another field
experiment at the Musgrave research farm
in Aurora replicated monocultures and
this time we planted them at 0 85 and
170 kilograms of nitrogen prac there
that we can assay there their response
and their effects on the rhizosphere
both that a nitrogen limited conditions
and presumably to nitrogen excess as
well
now nitrogen management management is
not the only thing that's changed over
the course of this history and certainly
planting density is a major change and
so we we used an intermediate planning
density of about 60,000 plants per
hectare that allowed us to maintain
nitrogen limiting conditions but also
our earliest releases could still
tolerate it and stand throughout the
season without falling over
at higher higher modern densities they
wouldn't be able to this experient
experiment also included 15n tracer and
that allows us to differentiate even
under fertilized conditions what the
plants are getting from soil pools
versus applied fertilizer from that
season I'm not actually going to share
that data with you just for for time
limitations and so we can plot the
changes the the yield of these hybrids
versus the years when they were released
and we can look for trends and what
should jump out
to you is this is not the hypothesis
that I originally presented instead if
we look at both grain yield and nitrogen
uptake there's positive trends with year
of release in both datasets so the
modern plants are modern hybrids are
higher yielding under high nitrogen
conditions and under low nitrogen
conditions but not only that they're
taking up more nitrogen under both
conditions as well and so it seems this
breeding history has actually improved
plant resource acquisition under
unfertilized conditions if we look at
their rhizosphere so another ordination
this is showing the centroids and the
standard error of the samples placement
on this ordination and if we color those
by year of release here these red points
are our earliest releases and these blue
points are our latest release releases
and what you see is they actually line
up very close together so there's not a
lot of difference between the first
releases and the and the latest releases
there is some significant differences
between the hybrids but those are
largely driven by the middle releases
that releases from the 1960s and 70s
which seem to be separating from the
group somewhat so our second hypothesis
that the microbial community is changing
there's been some changes but but not
exactly what we were predicting and this
becomes very clear if we look at
differential abundance of particular
taxa so this is comparing the abundance
of all of our taxa to the abundance in
the earliest release and we see no
differences no significant changes
through any of the hybrids except for
these middle release hybrids from the
60s 70s where we start to see some
change in the composition of that
community and if we look at the
I'm data again there is some variation
among the hybrids but it tells a similar
story the the modern and the oldest
releases are still rather similar to
each other in their enzyme profiles but
it's this release from the 1970s which
is really standing out and is distinct
from the others and so so where are we
you know we can reevaluate this idea
that maybe the luxury nitrogen has
relaxed selection and the microbial
community and if we if we look back to
this graph again the perhaps once in the
in this period from the 1960s and 70s
where there was rapid increases in
nitrogen applications to agricultural
lands perhaps then there was truly
luxuriant and great and surplus in the
systems but certainly over the last 30
to 40 years those nitrogen app rates of
nitrogen application have been stable
and yet yields have continued to go up
so nitrogen use efficiency has been
improving so it's possible that you know
for a while there was relaxed selection
and things have gone back to a stronger
selection I don't want to claim that
with only a couple of genotypes from
that that middle period but it it could
be interesting to look more closely at
those middle years and again these
changes in plant density that have
occurred alongside these changes in
fertility management may be maintaining
really strong intraspecific competition
for resources and therefore be providing
a stabilizing selection on some of these
rises for your traits alright so to
begin to wrap up and we saw that rises
for bacterial community composition was
linked with plant phylogeny and function
and this is exciting because it's a it
could be a potential tool for managing
rhizosphere communities and the
processes that they mediate in the field
and so if we can find different classes
of plants that are having
different impacts on the on the soil
environment we can incorporate those
into rotations we probably already are
and then influence the soil bacteria
bacteria community and the soil pools as
well so again do you know type effects
are evident in the data including within
the germ plasm from a commercial
breeding program but the mechanisms for
this are still a little unclear and
looking at the second experiment that I
showed with you this synchrony between
risers for your effects and nitrogen
uptake in the field I think is sort of a
foundation for understanding you know
where we might look for plant influences
on these processes and also the the
benefits of them and then finally the
breeding history at least modern hybrid
breeding has has maintained or enhanced
nitrogen uptake from soil pools while
leaving Rises for your assembly at least
amount that we can detect relatively
unchanged and so with that there's many
many people to acknowledge for this work
the towards sustainability foundation
actually give us our seed grant to get
our first project started and then the
usda hatch and the National Institute of
Food and Agriculture program provided
further funding to develop the work
further my committee Laurie Drinkwater
Margaret Smith Daniel Buckley had been
fantastic in supporting me less process
and I've learned an extreme amount from
them as well as the entire drink water
and Buckley labs you know you can't do
this work without your lab mates there's
a few that deserve particular mention
Heather Scott our research assistant in
the drink water lab was phenomenal help
in the fields she single-handedly must
have helped me salvage several
over-ambitious field projects Marisa
Weiss a former postdoc in the drink
water lab really trained me on the
biogeochemistry and the soil science
aspect of this nick Youngblood was a
postdoc working with Dan Buckley he's
now with Ruth Ruth clay at the
Max Planck Institute providing the
training for the microbial community
analysis in the bioinformatics so
without them I could not have done it
thank you to the horticultural section
for the support for the environment that
he provided for the years that I was
here as well as the cornell
undergraduate biology program the for
their funding as well there's many many
other people that deserve recognition
but I can't list them all here so with
that I'd like to say thank you for
having me and I would love to take your
questions yes this Geneva have any
questions not here that's easy the
nitrogen application in the Eagle that
you showed me that most of the points
were right there the black ones are
really on the two lines what are the
open circles oh so this is an analysis
from this paper and I believe there were
some funny things that happen to this
year like droughts other things that
artificially knocked down yields and so
those are there indication that's not on
the regression line Brian early in your
talk you mentioned a correlation between
rhizosphere
population and the mainly in gut and I
didn't understand that correlation at
all sure so it gets back to this
hypothesis of the organism evolutionary
history influenced the the microbiome
that that organism is selecting for and
we had seen that in the PO AC and so
Ruth ley did a study that was looking at
the evolution of mammals and the
phylogenetic relatedness of mammals and
the microbial community composition in
their gut and what they found was that
yes there was this relationship with
evolutionary history and particularly
once you controlled for food source or
the
the mammals diet then this relationship
was much stronger
so sort of informing our our current
businesses Thomas C buckwheat in there
and that is a plant that seems designed
to support a huge microbial community
briefly but yes perfectly designed for
that but I couldn't tell without the
waiting's weather that in fact those
characters yes no buckwheat is an
amazing plant and so early on one of the
first slides I showed shows a sort of a
picture of arises fear and that is
actually buckwheat forms these great
rise Oh sheets of so there must be some
polymers that's releasing that are
really just helping glue the soil
together and foster a microbial
community I didn't show the data but
it's enzyme activity is interesting and
it doesn't fall out on that axis of the
longer-lived higher nitrogen use
efficiency plants it's on the other end
but that's not to say that there's not
interesting stuff happening on that end
yeah it's a good one to study so sure so
to build on some of the work that I
presented here particularly the
Actinobacteria story right so there's my
hypothesis is that it has to do with
plant you know carbon soil or
rhizosphere carbon flow and
and in some ways you know that's
testable we can we can measure brute
oxidation we can manipulate the
environment the plants glowing and
growing in to slow down growth there are
some other alternative hypotheses I
think about why octina bacteria might be
selected for there's been some work
showing that they thrive in the
rhizosphere under drought conditions and
so we could imagine that maybe the
variation that we're attributing to
differences in in rhizosphere carbon
flow may actually have to do with these
plants impact on soil moisture status in
their eyes is fear but that again that
that again is testable we can manipulate
the water potential of the rhizosphere
and test whether or not you know certain
subsets of the community respond so
perhaps a place to start time for one
more question
Tom Brian are there any implications for
crop rotation from this you know a lot
of things it's it's been de rigueur for
a number of years but would you care to
speculate on how rotational cycles might
be informed by your data your findings
sure thank you for that question it's a
great question and one that I tried to
allude to but maybe not clearly enough
and so choosing the diversity of plants
that we plant in our agricultural
systems is really the primary one of the
primary management tools that we have
and rotations is is is a great one and
so we choose rotations for a number of
reasons you know we think of them often
from a plant pathogen perspective we can
break up the pathogen cycle I think I
think this data suggests that the
impacts on the broader microbial
community may also be important you know
so I wasn't testing pathogens but these
different groups with microbes if
they're having different impacts on the
soil environment and I think there's
reason to believe that they are from a
soil conditioning perspective you know
what you proceed or the the sequence in
the rotation may have very important
effects on the soil nutrient pools and
the group of microbes that's there to
take advantage of it in the next cycle
which would seem to imply that a chronic
monoculture maze is probably not
beneficial to the rises here
I think if if it's not broken up then we
can probably make a strong inference
that continuous maize cropping is not
the most beneficial things for soil
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu